it is so wonderful to see both of you
brady you
the fact you're twenty thousand dollar
richer i mean you gotta celebrate that
and coming in second come on and tear
out the underdog
coming into third place is a big
celebration so
how are you feeling i know you guys
didn't win but coming in second and
third
is pretty spectacular i mean i would
have liked some money
but it's okay okay
you know the 20k is very nice no it's
not a 100k
but i am you know still very thankful i
feel like everyone did such a good job
and i genuinely was happy with
any of the top three winnings true yeah
any of us i was very happy to see when
yeah and it's a historic moment the
first black man in
the franchise in north america to win
this is a moment
how does that work for you that you're
part of this historical moment yeah
oh it feels amazing to know that you
know representation was shown and that
on being on such a diverse cast that we
really
you know broke the mold and really you
know had like
went with this big paradigm shift that
this whole past year has been about
so it was really great to you know
really show that and represent that to
canada and the world
all right now let's talk about your yeah
yeah tara and let's talk about your
relationship bray with that tai
so do you have a crush on him did you
have a crush on him like what was what
was going on in the house
yeah what was going on
you guys are making me black of course
i have a question on tai who doesn't
have a crush on thai
you know he's very sweet he's very
dreamy
but i know that obviously we're just
really good friends you know
you really did become like a best friend
when i was in there someone that you
know i could really confide in
and really honestly it was just nice to
have someone like super close in there
you know yeah yeah especially after
austin left right we didn't know how
you're
gonna go right yeah and tara the fact is
you are a mom and you are fierce and we
saw love your emotions through this game
and
doubting your stuff and just questioning
your abilities and as a mother
it was really powerful to watch you the
way you were
and raw and real so you're pres you were
so
present and it was so important what you
did so for you to come
out of this house now knowing the impact
you had what does that feel for you i
just hope
um because you know being a mom it can
be a very like selfless job and
sometimes
as moms we forget about our dreams and
our superpowers
so if i could have just shown moms any
moms out there that you you can be a
great mom
and you can crush your dreams too then
that's
priceless to me you guys haven't seen
your family yet have you
no i haven't seen my kids and i'm
losing my mind i can't even imagine i
can't even imagine
uh you know and for you to have a
comeback you probably have the biggest
comeback
of the season against jetson i mean
what was going through your mind at that
point and how did it feel for you to win
and get back inside i literally felt
like
david versus goliath oh my god i have to
take on the guy who
sculpted out of marble um one on one and
i was
shaking in my boots i was shaking
especially he had two balls up there
yeah and i was like no like just don't
give up
and i just i just kept going for it it
was it was an incredible
moment because i don't even know if i
believed in myself that i could do that
so to do that um
it was it was very special what have you
learned about yourself through this
process i mean
you grew i almost feel like i think
um you always end i feel like people in
general we're always the hardest on
ourselves
we always underestimate ourselves and it
just reminds me you know you can do
hard things and you don't um
you know i may be a strength a strength
i thought i was strong before going into
the house and i just feel like i'm
leaving
as like a warrior you know it was i love
that
yeah it's very empowering yeah and
braden
uh to watch you how would you describe
your game because you
were very quiet sitting back and kind of
watching what everything was happening
how would you describe it i feel like
you know i was almost like a secret
assassin chair likes to say my game was
so good that you know it was almost
invisible
so i think you know by being a little
social butterfly
and you know just being like i'm the fun
guy that everyone wants to have around
you know i'm playing the game what are
you talking about
you know i think by laying low and kind
of downplaying you know how hard
everything was playing
i think that was like my biggest
strength and i knew coming into that
house that
i might not have been a combi so i knew
i really had to rely on the fact that
i am a very sociable person i do you
know i do a very bubbly personality
so i knew coming in i really had to rely
on that and i think that was one of my
greatest strengths in this game
and i will say first of all you won four
cops i think you are a compass
um and in that house there were so many
big egos that you couldn't be strong in
that house or you were going
like that is strategy in itself to be
like oh no no i'm not here i'm just you
know a fixture
that's that's a strategy
one of the most emotional moments was
when keeper left the house
and tara you know you you made that
happen
um it was a right move too because we
knew he was going to win that win at the
end
when you think of kiefer i mean what
does he represent to you
you know what um kiefer in the house was
very special to me and that was a very
difficult decision to make
but if i'm just being honest and
transparent like i felt like he
did me the dirtiest and they sent me
packing
i did so it wasn't even necessarily like
that i thought he would win the game
it was there was a little bit of
vengeance there for me because i did i
i told kiefer like i will go to war with
you
it is time and he he cut me
really quickly so i had to return the
favor you know another intense moment
was you and victoria and that
conversation you guys had i mean how did
you feel after that and
have you called it kudos and you guys
are good
um it's always in those moments
because we are so in our heads that we
don't think we deserve something so when
somebody says it out loud
um it hurts but victoria
is a beautiful wonderful person it is
water under the bridge like i i love her
i respect her i want
nothing but good things for her and she
is am i
she's a queen you know like there's
there's no ill feelings there
no so for both of you what was the best
moment for you to be in the house
i think just the best moment was just
honestly just like being with everyone i
really did love
the bb ken awards i feel like it was
really like the whole fam
got to be there together and just hang
out but honestly just being able to hang
out with such like incredible
genuine people and hang out with tara
and our final days together
i think are just like moments like
memories that i literally will cherish
forever and never forget
oh my for sure is gonna be winning that
final four veto
because i was so underestimated and i
smoked those three boys
yes i felt like a superhero
that was hands down one of the coolest
things i have ever done
in my life moms can keep up yes
and bray what are you gonna do with the
money are you gonna save it and put it
away and keep it you know are you gonna
splurge
i don't know you know i'm young i'm 23
and i might want to splurge but i need
to be smart with my money you know
he's responsible he's going to save it
he's already got it in stock that's
already
i love that you guys are absolutely
amazing this
is by far one of my favorite seasons and
it's because of
you two and the whole the whole cat
house guest where everyone together was
just
absolutely amazing so congratulations to
both of you
and uh i hope i can't wait for you guys
to see your family i mean it's time it's
time
it's time it is time not
wait
you